The next example of relationship we're going to look at is
the association relationship. This is a relationship in which objects of
one class are connected to objects of another. And it's
called an has a relationship. So it means that objects of
one class have objects of another class. So let's see
what that means. Let's do it by considering two classes in
our example system. The student class and the course offering class.
In this case, there is an association between the student and
the course offering, because the student is registering for the
course offering. So, in a sense, the course offering has students.
Contains students, to indicate this fact we add a solid
line between the student class and the course offering. And the
fact that having a solid line doesn't really tell us
much about the nature of the relationship, so to clarify such
nature we can use what we call adornments that we
can apply to associations we can add to associations to clarify
their meaning. In particular we can add a label to
an association and the label describes the nature of the relationship.
In this case, for example, it clarifies that the student
registers for CourseOffering. We can also add a triangle to
further clarify the direction of the relationship. So in this
case, the triangle will indicate that it's the student That registers
for the course offering, and not the other way around. Another
important adornment or limitation that we can put on an association,
is multiplicity. Multiplicity defines the number of instances of one
class that are related to one instance of the other
class. We can define multiplicity at either end of the
relationship. In this case, for instance, we can say that
if we look at the student, the student can register
for two or more course offerings. Whereas, if we look
at the course offering, we can say that each course
offering can have or can enroll between 1 and 50 students.
So as you can see by adding a label, a direction,
and multiplicity, we make it much clearer what the relationship is
and what it means and what are its characteristics. As we
saw when we introduced relationships, there is a different kind of
association, kind of a specialized one, which we call aggregation. So
here we're going to look at an example of an aggregation. So
first of all what is an aggregation? An aggregation is a
relationship between 2 classes in which 1 represents a larger class
like a whole which consists of smaller classes which are
the parts of this whole. So let's look at an example
in the context of our system. Let's consider a Course
and the CourseOffering. And in this case, we can see
that the Course consists of multiple CourseOfferings. So in
a sense, a course is a whole and the course offerings
are the parts of this whole. So this a perfect case
in which we will use an aggregation to express this relationship.
So we will add a solid line with a diamond on the side of the whole class
to indicate that the course consists of multiple course offerings.
And as we did for associations even though we
are not going to do it for this specific
example, we could also in this case add multiplicity
information on the aggregation to indicate how many classes
of the two types are involved in the relationships.